but tensions remain as president Trump
welcomes Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo
Abe a to his mar-a-lago estate today
amid concerns over trade and North Korea
the meeting between the two leaders came
as word that North and South Korea are
working to formally and the state of war
that has lasted more than 60 years
president Trump trying to reassure his
ally about his upcoming meeting the
meeting between himself and North Korean
leader Kim jong-un
but downplaying what could be a very
historic event chief White House
correspondent John Roberts reports on
the summit from Florida President Trump
today welcoming japan's Prime Minister
tomorrow logo for the second time the to
her friends and may play golf tomorrow
morning but these talks could be
contentious at times we're gonna be
discussing trade with Japan we are going
to be discussing military we're going to
be discussing security and we will I am
sure at the outset we're going to get
along and when it's all over we're going
to get along even better today word that
North and South Korea are working
towards signing an official peace
agreement to supersede the ceasefire
that has been in place for 65 years they
do have my blessing to discuss these
ends of the world the planned meeting
between President Trump and North Korean
leader Kim jong-un he's given Japan
heartburn Shinzo Abe a seeking
assurances from the president the
Japanese interest won't be given short
shrift great for North Korean issue I'd
like to underscore the importance of
achieving the complete verifiable and
irreversible denuclearization
as well as the abundance of missile
programs North Korea john wolf install
was senior director for arms control and
counter proliferation in the obama white
house he says ahve wants security
guarantees in any denuclearization deal
ah BAE doesn't want Trump to get a deal
that does that but leaves Japan
vulnerable to medium-range missiles and
residual nuclear capability and so they
want to coordinate the positions and
make sure Japan's not left out in the
cold
president Trump tried to calm those
fears today saying he will faithfully
represent Japan's interests if and when
he sits down with Kim they do respect us
we are respectful of them and we're
gonna see what happens we will bring up
the abductees we'll bring up many
different things I think it's a time for
talking but Prime Minister ah Bay may
hear less comforting talk when it comes
to trade President Trump is taking aim
at the 69 billion dollar trade deficit
the US has with Japan chief economic
adviser Larry Kudlow saying the trade
agenda will be comprehensive it's gonna
be about the exclusions from the
national security tariffs on steel it's
going to be about market opening
initiatives by Japan that's going to be
about TPP will be on the conversation
Japan wants to see the us back at the
trans-pacific partnership the president
Trump wants to negotiate a bilateral
free trade deal with Japan first the
president tweeting last week that the
u.s. already has bilateral deals with
six of the 11 nations in TPP and are
working to make a deal with the biggest
of those nations Japan who has hit us
hard on trade for years he's not a big
fan of these multilateral agreements
he'd rather go country to country so
called bilateral like words gonna talk
with Japan tomorrow there today and
tomorrow so we'll see about this
man is worried that President Trump may
link trade and security with a message
that if Japan wants security assurances
on North Korea it needs to move on trade
the president Trump also revealed today
that the White House has been having
direct talks with North Korean officials
about setting up that summit with Kim
jong-un and likely in either late May or
early June and that they have narrowed
down the location for those talks to
five possible sites though no word on
what those sites are president Trump
sounding optimistic about the
opportunity to sit down with Kim but at
the same time saying we'll see maybe not
right and John a little bit of a dust-up
it seems inside the administration
tonight you had the US ambassador to the
United Nations nikki Haley yesterday
saying that Russian sanctions more of
them were on the way possibly as soon as
this week and then you had a response
talking to Dana Perino after Larry
Kudlow said she might have been confused
quote with all due respect I don't get
confused seems like there may be a
back-and-forth hacking in there a little
bit of a back-and-forth there Brett we
heard from the White House in a
statement yesterday that nothing has
changed they're still considering
sanctions but nothing to announce at
this time but for the very first time an
administration official was asked about
this in person Larry Kudlow always tells
people what's on his mind and today he
said that nikki Haley got a little ahead
of the curve there was perhaps a
momentary confusion there which prompted
her to give that sharp retort she
apparently according to Dana Perino has
been trying to get in touch with Kudlow
all day he hasn't been taking her call
cuz he's wrapped up in this Japan
bilateral but she is going to try to get
him tonight and I don't want to be him
when she does all right John Roberts
traveling with the president John thanks